voilà donc quelques minutes de retard
mais je pensais ne pas pouvoir ouvrir la
séance de cette après-midi d'audition je
vous remercie bien sûr d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation nous débutons donc
notre travaux aujourd'hui par l'audition
de plusieurs responsables du service
statistique du Commissariat général du
développement durable qui sont en charge
de l'Observatoire national de la
rénovation énergétique et collaborer
étroitement à l'enquête logement qui est
menée périodiquement par l'INSEE alors
il s'agit de Monsieur Jérôme harnois
cherche en même temps la personne voilà
ce directeur des statistiques du
logement et de la construction
de Madame Bérengère Meski sous
directrice des statistiques de l'énergie
de madame Béatrice boutique
responsable des études et synthèses sur
le logement et la construction à la
sous-direction des statistiques du
logement de la construction de Monsieur
Ronan Le Saout expert en économie de
l'énergie et en méthodologie statistique
à la sous-direction des statistiques et
de l'énergie et monsieur Guillaume
rateau vous nous avez rejoint donc par
rapport aux personnes qui étaient
préalablement donc
identifié alors j'arrive chef du bureau
des enquêtes et synthèse sur le logement
et la construction de l'Observatoire
national de la rénovation énergétique
donc merci à toutes et tous de votre
présence donc la Commission a souhaité
votre audition pour progresser sur trois
sujets la compréhension de la
gouvernance de la politique de
énergétique
l'état actuel du parc de logement et la
mesure de l'efficacité des aides
concernant la gouvernance de la
politique de rénovation nous voudrions
comprendre comment se positionne
l'Observatoire national de la rénovation
énergétique dans le dispositif public et
quelle mission précise lui sont confiées
nous avons notamment retenu de
l'audition de Madame la Ministre
Emmanuel wargon qu'aucune politique ne
pouvait être pilotée sans une
connaissance statistique fiable
concernant le parc de logement et alors
que la France s'est donné des objectifs
ambitieux avec en vue un parc devenu
économe en 2050 ou en étant aujourd'hui
alors que depuis plusieurs années on
souhaite réaliser 500 000 rénovations
par an sans pour autant jamais y
parvenir de quelle donnée dispose-t-on
alors que le DPE reste très critiqué
combien y a-t-il de passoires thermiques
et à l'inverse de logement déjà aux
normes souhaitées pour 2050 enfin
troisième volet concernant l'efficacité
des aides peut-on mesurer les gains en
termes d'émission de gaz à effet de
serre ou d'énergie consommée arrive-t-on
à savoir combien de logements sortent du
statut de passoire thermique c'est
évidemment central pour ajuster les
moyens déjà très important aux objectifs
poursuivis alors que la Cour des comptes
a par exemple vivement critiqué les
résultats obtenus
l'ensemble de ces données vous
permettent-ils d'identifier des points
noirs par exemple de sur-représentation
des passoires thermiques des points de
blocage pour la réalisation des travaux
ou au contraire des leviers d'action qui
pourraient être actionnés enfin pour
reprendre les propos du président de la
République dans une récente vidéo postée
sur les réseaux sociaux peut-on mesurer
là où est maximale l'efficacité d'un
neuro-publique pour atteindre nos
objectifs en matière de transition
énergétique est-ce exact qu'il vaudrait
mieux aujourd'hui investir dans les
transports plutôt que dans la rénovation
avez-vous sur ce sujet des éléments de
réponse à nos données avant de vous
laisser la parole pour répondre à cette
première question et pour un propos
introductif d'une vingtaine de minutes
que vous répartirez comme bien sûr vous
le souhaitez il me revient de vous
indiquer que cette audition est diffusée
en direct et en différé sur le site
internet du Sénat et qu'un compte-rendu
sera publié je dois également vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête serait
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende je vous invite
donc à prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité et à lever la
main droite et à dire je le jure
merci mesdames et messieurs donc vous
avez la parole ensuite de votre
intervention bien sûr monsieur le
rapporteur prendra à son tour la parole
pour vous poser un certain nombre de
questions et nous ouvrirons ensuite
aussi les questions avec nos collègues
qui sont présents à cette audition donc
je ne sais pas qui commence je vous
laisse la parole
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente je
pense qu'on va commencer rapidement
comme vous l'avez souhaité par une
présentation des résultats de l'enquête
logement et ensuite on présentera plus
largement les travaux de l'Observatoire
national de la rénovation énergétique
d'accord
excusez-moi je pensais que
voilà donc vous avez souhaité nous
entendre sur l'enquête nationale
logement
donc c'est une enquête qui a une
ancienneté importante elle a débuté en
1955 la lui à peu près tous les 5 ans 5
ans
très bien donc qui est normalement mené
par l'INSEE donc le millésime précédent
en date de 2013 et exceptionnellement le
millésime 2020 a été réalisé par nos
services en fait donc par la
sous-direction donc des statistiques sur
le logement et la construction sur un
champ un peu plus restreint qui est
celui de la métropole donc les
territoires outre-marins n'ont pas été
n'ont pas été prises en compte cette
fois-ci et pour voir le cadre en fait il
y a également rattrapage puisque il y a
déjà une le millésime suivant est déjà
prévu et la collecte de ce millésime
aura lieu à l'été 2023 et sera fait par
l'INSEE sur l'ensemble du pays
cette enquête donc couvre un champ assez
large de thématique qui vont à la fois
du parc du logement la qualité de
l'habitat des dépenses
un point important dessus des ressources
des taux d'efforts des opinions sur le
logement mobilité résidentiel etc
l'équipement énergétique qui est pour le
coup pour le dans le cadre de cette
audition un intérêt particulier
le questionnaire est globalement
comparable d'un millésime sur l'autre
qui permet d'avoir des mesures d'évoles
d'évolution qui sont possibles d'autre
part c'est une enquête fait partie des
plus gros dispositifs
d'enquête dans la stade de la
statistique publique puisque enfin il y
a 37000 ménages qui ont répondu à cette
enquête ce qui permet donc une très
large déclinaison
d'études possibles
également donc l'enquête est large
également par le l'importance du nombre
de questions qui sont posées puisqu'il y
a à peu près 1500 variables dans
l'enquête
il y a un besoin
administratif par rapport à cette
enquête de réponse sur certains
chiffrages notamment les loyers imputés
qui sont qui rentrent dans le calcul du
PIB et qui sont construits à partir de
cette enquête
sinon bah ça couvre un grand nombre dans
un grand nombre d'acteurs sont une
attente sur ce sur l'ensemble de ces de
ces résultats
l'enquête est majeure dans le sens
également où il y a certains indicateurs
qui sont de référence et produits à
partir de cette enquête notamment sur
les conditions de logement et sur la
partie financière des de qu'est-ce qui
sont supportés par les ménages donc à la
fois le donc il y a le taux de surplombe
surpeuplement des ménages qui sont
produits par cette enquête également les
taux d'efforts donc taux d'efforts qui
se décline en taux d'effort énergétique
également précarité énergétique
le contexte et le suivant en fait pour
le millésime 2020 donc l'enquête a des
débuté fin 2019 elle s'attache fait au
printemps 2021 et a subi les
conséquences des mesures mises en place
pour lutter contre le covid et donc
après un certain retard le fait que les
travaux statistiques sont encore en
cours et donc ça devrait s'achever au
troisième trimestre de cette année
il y a une première publication qui a
été faite et je pense qui a attiré votre
attention donc qui a été faite
mi-décembre sur les conditions de
logement donc ça c'est vraiment le
premier premières exploitations faites à
partir de ce millésime ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que dans les quelques mois
à venir vont paraître d'autres éléments
importants notamment sur le parc
énergétique donc
sur le qui donne un bilan de du parc de
logement par rapport à l'énergie les
taux d'efforts donc que sont une donnée
importante avec l'ordre déclinaisons
taux d'énergétique taux de taux d'effort
énergétique également peut se servent
également à d'autres
d'autres études donc on est cité une ici
sur notamment s'interroger et sur le cas
particulier des logements qui se situent
dans le cadre des zones de protection
patrimoniales donc il recouvre un cas un
peu particulier notamment regarde de
décompte de la qualité de ses logements
et de leur performance énergétique
oui bonjour à tous et à toutes donc je
vais vous présenter quelques résultats
vous présentez quelques résultats de la
publication donc évoqué avec Monsieur
rateau de décembre donc ce sont des
résultats qui restent préliminaires
comme cette handicap
en préalable il y a notamment des
questions de pondération qui pourraient
encore évoluer à la suite mais je pense
que dans les grandes lignes on peut
quand même s'y fier pour faire passer un
certain nombre de messages et donc
notamment on a choisi de vous présenter
des résultats concernant les défauts
majeurs de confort alors qui vont
nettement au-delà de des questions de
performance énergétique qui sont censés
enfin voilà retracer des un ensemble de
dimensions de confort des logements
pas mal plus vastes donc ce graphique
présente le la part de logement
présentant au moins un défaut majeur de
confort par statut d'occupation type de
logement donc entre collectif et
individuel et période cette occupation
donc avec les logements les plus anciens
qui sont ceux d'avant 49 et la période
de construction la plus récente qui
commence en 2010 et donc ce qu'on peut
constater c'est que quel que soit la
période d'occupation on a une proportion
de logements présentant un défaut majeur
qui est plus élevé parmi les locataires
du parc social et dans une moindre
mesure du parc privé que parmi les
propriétaires occupants et que cette
proportion diminue nettement avec le
l'année de construction même s'il y a
une petite stagnation pour les
locataires entre les la période qui suit
immédiatement la prière et la période 75
peut-être oui pour aller plus en détail
justement dans ces défauts majeurs de
confort donc les principaux sont repris
ici et donc on a simplement surligné en
gras à la fin celui qui va peut-être
plus vous intéresser qui a un lien plus
direct avec le la performance
énergétique c'est la proportion de
logements et en moins une fenêtre
laissant passer l'air voilà on voit que
cette proportion est bien plus élevée
parmi les locataires aussi dans le parc
privé que dans le parc social que chez
les propriétaires occupants et si elle
diminue pour les propriétaires occupants
et les locataires du parc privé entre
2013 et 2020 ce n'est pas le cas parmi
les locataires du parc social
et donc par ailleurs on peut aussi
s'intéresser à un autre ensemble de
défauts
donc ils sont pas considérés comme des
défauts majeurs mais dont un certain
nombre à très la performance énergétique
des logements donc notamment la
proportion de logements trop difficiles
à chauffer les logements présentant un
défaut en terme de d'humidité présence
d'humidité des problèmes d'isolation du
toit ou des murs et enfin le manque
d'aération dans les logements
et donc ce qu'on voit c'est que sur la
plupart enfin pour la plupart de ces
défauts il y a quand même une nette
amélioration entre 2013 et 2020 pour
enfin quel que soit le statut de
d'occupation
notamment donc les pour les problèmes
d'isolation on a une amélioration quelle
que soit le statut d'occupation c'est
également le cas pour les logements trop
difficiles à chauffer et voilà et par
ailleurs donc ça ça reste des fois assez
qui sont mesurées de façon relativement
objectifs et constante au cours du temps
il y a d'autres questions qui sont
posées dans l'enquête donc par exemple
sur les ménages qui déclarent avoir
souffert du froid donc ça évidemment ça
peut dépendre aussi de l'année d'enquête
il peut y avoir des des années plus ou
moins enfin difficile en terme de
ressenti mais
là dessus donc on peut quand même
regarder ce qui se passe en 2020 et on
voit que les c'est les locataires du
parc social qui déclarent le plus
souvent avoir souffert du froid l'hiver
précédent l'enquête
voilà
voilà donc j'enchaîne directement donc
sur sur les travaux plus généraux de
l'Observatoire national de rénovation
énergétique alors quelques mots sur les
missions et la gouvernance de cette
observatoire donc c'est un observatoire
qui a été créé en septembre 2019 par
lettre de mission d'Emmanuel vargon et
Julien de Normandie qui a pour vocation
de d'améliorer la connaissance
sur la rénovation à la fois dans le
résidentiel et dans le tertiaire donc ça
c'est l'objectif général avec du coup
trois missions principales qui sont
caractérisées l'état du parc de logement
suivre la dynamique de la rénovation
suivre les dispositifs de soutien et
donc les aides à la rénovation et donc
sur ces trois missions là avec l'idée
c'est de diffuser le plus possible des
études et de mettre à disposition des
données à la fois au niveau national et
au niveau territorial
pour éclairer l'action publique
en termes de gouvernance c'est un
observatoire donc qui est piloté par le
service statistique vous l'avez dit
madame la Présidente
donc on en assure le secrétariat ensuite
il y a trois instances c'est plutôt deux
instances principales un comité
stratégique qui est interne
administration qui regroupe un
administration plus adhem donc il
regroupe notamment la direction
d'habitat de l'urbanisme et des paysages
la direction générale de l'énergie du
climat l'ADEME
oui la dame est puis le zeste le CGDD
qui du coup définit plutôt les
orientations il valide le programme de
travail et puis on a un comité des
partenaires qui est beaucoup plus large
qui composer d'environ 25 membres qui se
réunit une à deux fois par an
c'est pas encore c'est pas forcément de
toutes les années la même chose et donc
il est le plus à qui on présente les
résultats qui les discutent et qui et
puis qui peut avoir
émettre des propositions sur les études
à mener et en parallèle de ces deux
instances on a aussi des groupes de
travail Haddock qu'on peut mettre enfin
qu'on met en place de temps en temps
particulier par exemple en ce moment on
a un groupe de travail sur l'évaluation
du coût des travaux de rénovation
c'est donc là on associe les acteurs
intéressés par le sujet ou les enfin en
fonction du en fonction du thème on peut
aller au-delà des membres de l'ONU
ça c'était la gouvernance ensuite je
présente enfin j'ai un PowerPoint qui
est assez long donc je vais pas
forcément tout vous présenter j'ai
peut-être balayé assez rapidement ce
qu'il y a dans le powerpoint et puis
n'hésitez pas à me dire s'il y a des
sujets que vous voulez que qu'on creuse
particulièrement parce que voilà c'est
quand même assez vaste et travaux donc
le premier enfin du coup je vous
présente la 3 publications plus ou moins
récentes qui permettent d'illustrer le
type de travaux qu'on mène au sein de la
nénéreux la première c'est sur le parc
du logement par classe de performance
énergétique qu'on a publié en juillet
2022 donc là l'idée c'est d'essayer
d'estimer la répartition des DPE sur
l'ensemble du parc de logements en
termes de données ce qu'on a c'est une
base qui est collectée par l'ADEME qui
répertorie l'ensemble des diagnostics de
performance énergétique qui sont
réalisés
le problème de cette base c'est que le
DPE ce enfin c'était eux ne sont pas
fait aléatoirement dans l'ensemble du
parc du logement c'est en général au
moment de la mise en location ou de la
mise en vente dans le logement et puis
et puis au moment de la
commercialisation des logements neufs
donc il y a un billet de cette base vers
des des étiquettes moins énergivores
donc il y a un petit travail statistique
pour réussir à à partir de cette base à
extrapoler et à estimer les DPE sur
l'ensemble du parc de logements donc ça
c'est le travail qu'on a mené dans cette
publication
voilà et donc ce qu'on les résultats
qu'on obtient c'est globalement au
profit de estimation au 1er janvier 2022
sur les 30 millions de résidences
principales on a environ 5,2 millions de
passoires énergétiques donc étiquette FG
à l'inverse 1,5 millions qui serait A ou
B 5 donc toujours de résidence
principale et puis
l'étiquette D qui est la plus fréquente
qui ferait 32% du parc
ensuite je repère je passe un peu vite
mais n'hésitez pas à me dire s'il faut
que j'aille plus lentement on a des
passoires énergétiques qui sont plus
nombreuses dans les résidences
secondaires et dans les logements
vacants
ce qui est pas forcément étonnant
notamment parce que résidences
secondaires sont pas forcément occupés
toute l'année donc ils sont pas
forcément chauffer toute l'année
et un total du coup de sur l'ensemble du
parc de 7,2 millions de passoires
énergétiques donc l'étiquette F et G
en termes de répartition dans le parc on
a plus de
plus de passoires dans le parc locatif
privé
on a 43% de logements qui sont classés
une précision sur quand vous parlez des
passoires thermiques vous parlez bien de
FG
et du tout pas du coup là dans ce que
vous
il est pas sûr c'est exclusivement
j'ai plus qu'ils sont en général du Fuge
été confiées il y avait eu des
évaluations au sein du service
statistique oui avant que ce soit le N
re le service statistique mené en partie
des études il y avait notamment une
enquête qui s'appelait Phébus qui visait
à justement calculer les DPE sur
un échantillon de logement avait calculé
des DPE donc ça c'était en
2012 voilà donc il y a eu voilà c'était
moins moins suivi moins fourni mais il y
avait déjà effectivement des travaux
ensuite sur les DPE là ce que je vous
présente c'est les résultats au 1er
janvier 2022 il y avait déjà eu une
évaluation du parc au 1er janvier ou 1er
juillet 2017
la méthodologie du DPE ayant changé
entre temps on compare pas on peut pas
voilà on peut pas faire de comparaison
donc je peux pas vous dire si le nombre
de passoires a augmenté baissé par
rapport à avant puisqu'en fait le DPE a
changé
5-2 sur les résidences principales
5 2 17 c'est quoi
oui oui
moi j'ai bien continuer mais je vous
avais plus le
ensuite j'ai je sais pas si
ça va revenir
on continue donc du coup ce que je
disais donc pas plus de passwords dans
le parc locatif privé un peu moins dans
le parc social à l'inverse
également plus de passoires thermiques
dans les maisons individuelles
dans les petits logements qui sont plus
énergivores dans les logements chauffés
au fioul parce qu'aujourd'hui vous savez
que l'étiquette DPE elle combine à la
fois une partie d'énergie et une partie
climat donc assez logiquement les
logements se fait au fil sont aussi
moins performants plus de passoire dans
l'agglomération parisienne
et puis
et puis quand on regarde les ménages du
premier quintile dans le parc privé ils
sont plus souvent dans des passoires
énergétiques que les autres classes de
revenus et aussi quand même un effet que
des rénovations des réglementations
thermiques
mises en place progressivement on voit
que les logements les plus récents sont
quand même plus performants
alors deuxième type de travaux qui est
mené par l'ONU c'est le suivi des
rénovation c'est la deuxième mission
donc là on vient de publier un rapport
sur les aides c'est principal d'aide à
la rénovation entre 2016 et 2020 donc ce
qu'on a c'est des détaillés sur le
crédit d'impôt à la transition
énergétique on est sur le passé ça
existe depuis aujourd'hui mais voilà
laisser de œufs ma prime rénove et
habiter mieux sérénité
globalement on a des données sur ma
prime rénov qui sont disponibles assez
rapidement en revanche les C2E ça met un
peu de temps à remonter donc c'est
plutôt des années sur lesquelles on a
deux ans de retard
et qui nécessitent un travail important
sur les fichiers C2 pour récupérer
récupérer les bonnes adresses éviter les
doubles comptes
donc ce qu'on voit dans les fichiers
d'aide c'est que en 2020 il y a 2,1
millions de logements qui ont bénéficié
enfin en France pour les proposition
bénéficier d'une aide à la rénovation
que ce soit enfin ces deux œufs cite ma
prime rénov ou habitait mieux sérénité
quel que soit le geste réalisé
et si on regarde sur le passé entre 2016
et 2020 on a entre 1,7 et 2,4 millions
de logements et enfin de logement aidé
selon les années
et donc on voit là sur le
[Musique]
enfin qui apparaît sur sur le graphique
en termes d'énergie conventionnelle
alors avec les
à partir des fichiers d'aide en fonction
du type de geste de rénovation ce qu'on
peut calculer c'est des économies
d'énergie conventionnelle donc théorique
c'est pas forcément les vrais économies
d'énergie réalisée par les ménages mais
ça donne quand même une idée des gestes
les plus les plus efficaces en termes
d'économie d'énergie et donc ce qu'on
voit dans les aides c'est que on a à peu
près
réalisé en 2020 des travaux qui
correspondent à 7,7 terawattheure par an
d'économie d'énergie conventionnelle
donc 1,7% de la consommation totale
d'énergie finale du parc de résidence
principale
et ce qu'on voit c'est que sur entre
deux 2016 et 2020 ce gain énergétique
moyen conventionnel s'est accru
donc il est passé de 2,8 MWh par
logement à 3,6 en 2020
par geste donc si on regarde les
économies totales générées par les aides
la plupart viennent la plupart des
économies donc théorique toujours sont
réalisées à partir de travaux sur le
chauffage et le jeu de sanitaire 57%,
puis ensuite l'isolation des toitures et
plancher 38% viennent ensuite les
fenêtres volées et portes et puis la
ventilation qui est qui est mineure ce
qu'on voit aussi c'est que l'isolation
des fenêtres à la part des économies
réalisées par l'isolation des fenêtres a
tendance à décroître au cours du temps
mais ça ça vient du fait que les
isolation des fenêtres a été de moins en
moins aidé à le remplacement des
fenêtres a été de moins en moins aidé au
cours du temps
ensuite d'autres résultats donc surtout
des maisons individuelles qui sont qui
bénéficient d'aide dans les C2E à
l'inverse enfin par l'inverse mais les
c2os se distinguent quand même parce que
il y a une part plus importante de
logements collectifs et notamment de
logement du parc social qui sont aidés
paresseux
en termes de ciblage sur les revenus MPR
et habiter mussérinité sont plutôt
ciblées sur les ménages modestes le C2E
c'est c'est plus équilibré et puis cite
assez logiquement c'était plutôt les
ménagé c'est parce que c'était des
machins imposables
et en termes
c'est un crédit d'impôt oui c'est vrai
non c'est pas seulement les imposables
j'ai dit une bêtise excusez-moi
bon c'était quand même plutôt les ménagé
et des gains énergétiques qui sont qui
sont concentrés plutôt dans une
diagonale entre entre les Pyrénées et le
reste de la France
et puis moins important dans le climat
dans le bassin méditerranéen c'est
logiquement parce que le climat est il
est moins rigoureux
dans les aides on a on a forcément
exclusivement la rénovation idée et ce
qui manque aujourd'hui c'est la
rénovation ce sur quoi on a aucune
information aujourd'hui c'est cela
rénovation d'un aidée de l'habitat
collectif on essaie d'y pallier
dans notre ami 2020 ce qu'on voit c'est
que on a 3,1 en 2019 3,1 million de
ménages qui ont réalisé 5 millions de
gestes de rénovation pour une économie
d'énergie de 8,1 encore une fois
économie conventionnelle on a toujours
pas d'économie réelle d'énergie
avec du coup
des gains plus importants quand il y a
des bouquets de travaux parce que quand
on a trois postes trois postes de
travaux ou plus c'est 30% des gains
énergétiques pour 2019
sur les postes enfin sur les gestes on
retrouve un peu comme dans le fichier
d'aide une prédominance des gains liés
aux travaux sur le changement de
chauffage puis l'isolation des murs la
ventilation
toiture plancher
on a regardé également donc à partir de
trémy les réductions de gaz à effet de
serre selon le poste
et donc là
on retrouve à peu près le même ordre que
pour les le même ordre de la même
classification que pour l'économie
d'énergie en revanche un impact beaucoup
plus important des travaux sur le
chauffage
faut pas non plus forcément déduire de
ça enfin c'est les économies
conventionnelles
qui fonctionnent
l'isolation plus les plus la maison est
isolée plus le changement de de
chaudière aura des impacts pour être
efficace et optimale
sur les motivations donc la principale
motivation des ménages pour la
rénovation c'est la réduction du montant
de la facture énergétique
et sur le ressenti la plupart 70% des
ménages qui ont réalisé des travaux de
rénovation donc toujours en maison
individuelle déclare une amélioration du
confort thermique
et ont plutôt également une déclare
plutôt une une baisse de la de leurs
dépenses d'énergie
sur les freins et les blocages
la au-delà du fait que certaines maisons
sont déjà performantes le premier frein
qui vient c'est la situation financière
donc c'est vraiment le coup des travaux
et enfin sur la planification des futurs
travaux
il y en a quand même près des trois
quarts des ménages qui ont déjà rénové
entre 2017 et 2019 qu'estime qu'ils ont
encore des travaux à réaliser mais
qu'ils n'ont pas planifié et là encore
la principale justification c'est la
situation financière
donc ça c'était les travaux récents de
plus ou moins récents de l'onre parce
que très vite déjà 2020 un petit point
sur les travaux qu'on a prévu de mener
la première c'est sur l'estimation des
gains énergétiques réels de consommation
réelle puisque je vous ai dit pour
l'instant nous on sait que calculer des
gains conventionnels donc ce qu'on
voudrait voir c'est effectivement
comment les enfin comment l'évolution la
consommation des ménages évolue après
une rénovation parce qu'on sait qu'il
peut y avoir deux effets qui qui jouent
par rapport à aux gains au gains
théorique le premier qui est un effet
rebond les ménages sont chauffés plus
en puisqu'ils pour le même prix ils vont
avoir une température plus agréable ou
une qualité des travaux qui serait moins
bonne que prévu
et donc pour ça
il est prévu qu'on accède à des
consommations
j'aurais bien pris juste un verre d'eau
si c'était possible
merci beaucoup
voilà donc il est prévu quand on accède
aux données de consommation mensuelle
d'un million de ménages qu'on a à Paris
ré
avec les fichiers d'aide à la rénovation
pour permettre de voir comment évoluer
les consommations de ces ménages avant
et après rénovations il est comparé à
des ménages qui n'ont pas rénovés et
voir également si effectivement une
différence d'évolution des consommations
entre des ménages qui ont rénové des
ménages qui ont parlé merci beaucoup
deuxième projet qu'on a en cours c'est
les principaux projets il y en a
d'autres mais voilà c'est on va
renouveler l'enquête sur la rénovation
des maisons individuelles trémie mais
les tendres au logement collectif et
donc aux copropriété de plus de 10
logements parce que les petites
copropriétés sont sous-estimées sous
représentées pardon aujourd'hui dans le
registre de Lana donc on n'arriverait
pas être représentatif
donc voilà donc l'allergie aux
copropriété depuis des logements et au
logement du parc social et dans cette
enquête on va essayer d'interroger à la
fois les
occupants des logements les
propriétaires bailleurs les bailleurs
sociaux et les syndics pour avoir une
vision complète des travaux à la fois
dans le logement
et dans les parties communes
donc ça y est prévu comme interroge à
l'automne 2022
vas-y
donc dernière partie on a beaucoup
présenté travaux effectués ou à venir
sur le résidentiel et on l'a dit dans
les objectifs de l'on re ça couvre aussi
le champ du tertiaire mais qui est pour
l'instant en fait et c'est ce qu'on veut
montrer dans ce dans ce graphique et
relativement mal couvert d'un point de
vue statistique donc c'est un des enjeux
des mois et des années à venir c'est
d'arriver en fait à mieux caractériser
ce chant du des bâtiments tertiaires ou
des activités tertiaires parce
qu'effectivement il peut y avoir des
bâtiments multi-activité avec tout
d'abord une analyse des différentes
sources de données qui sont disponibles
donc on a déjà effectué une analyse
qualité de la base hospit qui se
concentre sur les bâtiments de l'État
avec donc une base qui contient pour
certains bâtiments des données très
détaillées et qui permettent d'analyser
individuellement la situation de
performance énergétique de certains
bâtiments ce qui pourrait être lié à des
actions politiques publiques mise en
oeuvre sur ces bâtiments mais qui ne
permet pas de diffuser des statistiques
agrégées du fait de défauts de
couverture ou d'exhaustivité
donc là on s'attache ces prochains mois
à analyser la qualité statique des
remontées via l'outil opéra donc les
remontées des actes
des assujettis donc ou à des critères en
termes de consommation et d'obligation
de de baisse de consommation d'énergie
pour évaluer en fait si les statistiques
agrégées sur la situation du parc
tertiaire pourrait être diffusée de
manière élargie la question qu'on se
pose à moyen terme c'est de
éventuellement de de faire une enquête
statistique sur ce champ là sur la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
tertiaires un peu comme sur le modèle de
de Trello mais sur le mais sur le champ
du tertiaire donc
la conclusion sur ce chant du tertiaire
c'est qu'effectivement la connaissance
statistique actuellement et encore assez
et encore assez insuffisante et on
travaille à chercher à l'améliorer
juste n'hésitez pas à aller visiter le
site de l'on re parce qu'il y a des
choses beaucoup plus précises et
beaucoup plus vaste et on peut pas tout
présenter
ce stade est-ce que vous voulez rajouter
quelque chose ou est-ce que voilà donc
on laisse monsieur le rapporteur vous
posez un certain nombre de questions
merci merci madame la Présidente merci
pour déjà cette présentation et puis vos
différentes explications j'avais oui un
certain nombre de questions d'abord
d'ordre général savoir si dans les
différentes missions que vous avez pu
présenter et puis les analyses que vous
avez faites sur les
les on va dire les données que vous
pouvez que vous pouvez avoir et qui sont
à votre disposition est-ce que vous
pensez que sont elles sont suffisantes
je pense notamment aussi au DPE donc du
coup avec les modifications du DPE et
quelle problématique ça peut ça peut
comporter dans vos analyses et dans vos
études parce que c'est vrai comment
changer les règles en cours de route
c'est sûr que ça complexifie un petit
peu les choses et puis peut-être du coup
votre votre regard et votre vision
justement sur le sur le nouveau le
nouveau DPE
j'avais aussi une question sur
sur les sur les résidences secondaires
c'est vrai qu'on voit que c'est plutôt
dans les résidences secondaires par
rapport aux résidences principales on a
32% contre 17% sur les sur les passoires
thermiques est-ce que vous avez fait une
analyse plus précise à savoir si c'est
vraiment une
problématique du logement ou est-ce que
ça a été pondéré notamment par les les
émissions et leur taux d'occupation
notamment parce que c'est vrai qu'on
imagine bien que les raisons secondaires
ne sont pas ne sont pas
occupés de la même de la même manière et
puis j'avais une autre question aussi
sur
sur 20% des passoires thermiques sont
vous l'avez dit sont des maisons
individuelles
et 15% de logements collectifs avec
notamment une prépondérance en zone
rurale et dans l'agglomération
parisienne et je voulais savoir si dans
vos études vous avez
réfléchi ou en tout cas vous avez pu
analyser par par région ou localement en
tout cas est-ce qu'il y a une vision
plus locale puisqu'on voit qu'il y a des
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place qui
peuvent être très différents par région
par intercommunalité etc avec des
plateformes de rénovation et sur lequel
on voit qu'on a des effets plus ou moins
importants en termes de réalisation et
c'est vrai qu'on voit que la zone rurale
du coup est importante liée justement
aux maisons individuelles est-ce que du
coup vous avez vu vous avez la
possibilité en tout cas d'avoir ce
cadrage là sur des dispositifs qui
aurait pu être mis en place dans
certains dans certains secteurs
et puis une autre question sur la ce que
vous je l'ai vu passer sur sur la
qualité de la rénovation énergétique
puisque encore faut-il mettre en place
cette rénovation et avec les aides etc
mais après il y a la qualité et la
qualité réelle qu'on peut avoir derrière
et l'impact que ça peut avoir sur les
sur la consommation donc voir est-ce que
vous avez aussi des indicateurs sur cet
aspect là et puis
est-ce que aussi sur le type de
matériaux et notamment sur les matériaux
biosourcés ou sur l'utilisation de
matériaux que ce soit des matériaux plus
plus locaux on sait que j'avais vu une
étude où on était à peu près à 90% de
matériaux utilisés qui étaient plutôt
d'industrie pétrochimique est-ce que du
coup voilà vous avez des remontées ou en
tout cas vous pouvez avoir des des
données sur cette cette aspect là et
puis pour terminer pour laisser la place
à mes collègues sur la question aussi du
non recours
est-ce que j'imagine que c'est pas
simple mais est-ce que parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a parlé du cite c'est vrai
que j'étais étonné quand vous disiez que
c'était peut-être moins
pour les plus aisés mais en fait vu le
fonctionnement je vois je vois pas par
rapport trop à la prime rénov ou c'est
parce que oui effectivement il est
peut-être c'était peut-être mal compris
mais en tout cas est-ce que on a on a
des éléments sur le fait que voilà le du
non recours et des raisons de ce de ce
non recours voilà merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur messieurs mesdames les
sénateurs donc un petit complément moi
je m'exprimerai d'abord que sur la
première question parce que les trois
autres me semble relever plutôt des
collègues de la sous-direction énergie
ou plus généralement de l'observatoire
national en ce qui concerne les données
sont-elles suffisantes alors
je pense que par par voilà par l'exposé
de ma collègue Bérengère je pense que il
apparaît assez clairement que en
l'espace de moins de trois ans
le SDF c'est l'Observatoire ont quand
même plutôt fait des miracles je pense
qu'il faut quand même le dire dans un
contexte compliqué notamment par la
pandémie pourquoi des miracles puisqu'en
fait justement au moment où Madame
wargon A
comment a donné l'impulsion à la
création de l'observatoire on partait
vraiment de zéro et donc il y a eu tout
ce travail au cours des deux trois
dernières années de prise de compte
d'abord de recensement des sources
disponibles et puis des prises de
contact avec les conducteur de ces
données notamment du côté des C2E la
dège du côté enfin en ce qui concerne
donc les DPE l'ADEME et puis aussi Lana
en ce qui concerne donc les dispositifs
dont elle a la charge
donc c'est vrai qu'on arrive plutôt la
une espèce de plateau du coup par
ailleurs le Death Bérengère l'a montré
adapte aussi son système d'information
par exemple en complétant le dispositif
très mis par le dispositif très lot pour
l'élargir en fait au
collectif en fait au logement collectif
mais effectivement on arrive quand même
la plus tôt à une forme de palier alors
qu'est-ce qui manque il manque à mon
avis plusieurs choses la première c'est
déjà
une certaine rapidité de la
disponibilité des données
on s'appuie beaucoup sur les données
administratives et comme souvent dans ce
registre là on dépend donc justement des
organismes ou des administrations
productrices
donc Bérengère l'a dit par exemple sur
les C2E il y a un délai de disponibilité
de ces informations qui est quand même
assez difficile pour nous puisque si on
n'a pas de données on ne produit rien
voilà on est un peu au chômage technique
et c'est vrai ou on produit des choses
sur des années qui sont jugées un peu
trop anciennes et donc de ce fait ça
frustre les utilisateurs et ça pénalise
le pilotage voilà donc c'est vrai que
sur un certain nombre de dispositifs
dont les C2E il y a effectivement ce
sujet là il y a un autre sujet qui est
d'ordre technique et désolé de devoir
insister là-dessus c'est la capacité à
rapprocher les sources à faire des
jointures désolé pour la technicité mais
c'est vrai que nous c'est un sujet
auquel on est particulièrement sensible
sur la question du logement et plus
généralement des locaux et donc
aujourd'hui les travaux qui vous ont été
présentés
mobilise une force et un savoir-faire
qui est sans doute assez
disproportionnée par rapport aux enjeux
les sources sont assez peu adaptées de
jointures on est souvent obligé de
passer par la notion d'adresse par
exemple tout simplement et ben quand on
se penche sur le collectif une adresse
c'est plusieurs logements et du coup
quand on est amené à rapprocher des
données telles que les DPE on a parfois
du mal à trouver le bon logement pour le
don le bon DPE et donc sur ce sujet là
il y a effectivement des marges de
progrès importantes sur lesquelles on se
mobilise et donc j'en profite pour
annoncer même si c'est plutôt un projet
de court moyen terme désormais on
travaille nous le Death avec la
direction générale métier du côté du
ministère en charge notamment de
l'habitat la DHP je sais pas si vous
connaissez et puis aussi les l'INSEE et
puis la direction générale des finances
publiques justement pour élaborer un
système de répertoire des locaux qui
soient en fait mis à la disposition des
différents acteurs en charge
d'administrer justement des données sur
le logement et plus les généralement sur
les locaux donc on a commencé à
travailler sur ce projet depuis un
certain temps à peu près il y a deux ans
ça avance à un rythme assez moyen mais
ça connaît une accélération en 2023
puisque précisément un service
d'exposition du référentiel airlock aux
impôts des impôts gérés par les impôts
va permettre justement aux détenteurs de
telle base de données ou détenteurs de
certaines données d'introduire de
consulter le répertoire qui existe
aujourd'hui et qui est somme toute assez
exhaustif et donc de rapatrier dans leur
source de données dans leur base de
données l'invariant fiscale qui sert
aujourd'hui notamment la taxe
d'habitation et surtout à la taxe
foncière pour pouvoir rapprocher les
sources voilà donc c'est pas maintenant
c'est ce service sera en principe en
mode bac à sable c'est à dire en mode
expérimental à partir de la fin de
l'année mais on peut penser qu'à partir
de 2024 et 2025 la plupart des sources
qui ont été des facto évoqués par
Bérengère dans le cadre de l'exposé
pourront être rapprochés et du coup on
gagnera en qualité on gagnera aussi en
précision notamment géographique et en
qualité des indicateur icateurs voilà je
veux pas être trop long mais il me
semblait que c'est précisions étaient
importantes
la première question donc du coup sur
les sur les résidences secondaires on
n'a pas fait d'analyses spécifiques on
les on les a on les a introduites pour
la première fois là dans cette dans
cette publication sur sur le parc de
logement on a enfin voilà c'est pour ça
qu'on les a un peu mis à part parce
qu'on nous apparaît que c'est comme une
problématique un peu différente de celle
des résidences principales on n'a pas
pondéré particulièrement par le taux
d'occupation je pense qu'on a je sais
pas où est-ce qu'on récupère des données
sur le taux d'occupation des résidences
secondaires
je pense pas qu'on ait d'informations
dessus donc voilà on les a juste mis à
part et c'est vrai ça nous paraissait
pas être pour l'instant pour le
prioritaire faut les travaux de on re
mais ça a un sujet qu'il faudrait sans
doute regarder un moment ou un autre
sur la question des de la précision
géographique alors dans dans l'étude on
a publié des données au niveau
départemental il me semble sur le site
de l'onrn voilà ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'en fait ça reste une
méthodologie statistique donc on peut
pas descendre à un niveau trop fin et
par ailleurs on peut pas
on reste c'est pour ça qu'on reste au
niveau départemental parce qu'on
pourrait pas vraiment tenir vu qu'on
estime le DPE des logements à partir des
DPE réalisés et puis des
caractéristiques des logements on n'aura
pas suffisamment d'informations pour
pouvoir se rendre compte que sur un
territoire
pas très important il y a eu un
dispositif mis en place qui permet de
réduire les tracesoires ça on n'est pas
capable de le de le voir dans notre il y
aura un petit effet au niveau
statistique au niveau global c'est bon
mais on aura enfin au niveau local ça
peut on n'aura pas cette précision là je
serai compléter si
et
du coup sur ma zone rurale et
agglomération parisienne où il fasse une
question de type de bâtie c'est vrai que
les maisons individuelles en fait elles
ont plus de surface de déperdition donc
c'est pour ça aussi qu'elles sont
souvent plus
classées en passoire énergétique
sur les indicateurs sur la qualité de la
rénovation et le type de matériaux à ma
connaissance on a enfin la qualité on a
rien ce type de matériaux je pense qu'on
a rien dans les aides non plus donc pour
l'instant on n'a pas on n'a pas grand
chose
et sur le non recours aux aides c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on a regardé dans
trémie je sais pas dans quelle mesure on
pourrait l'ajouter un Trello sur le cite
en fait ce que je me dis c'est
qu'effectivement c'est un crédit d'impôt
mais ça reste enfin il y a une question
de délai avant d'avoir le remboursement
qui peut avoir joué sur sur des
populations plus dans des situations
financières moins facile
mais effectivement peut-être que le non
recours aux aides c'est une question
qu'on pourrait essayer de façon à sujet
qu'on pourrait essayer de creuser dans
la prochaine édition de l'enquête
de la rénovation des logements je te
laisse compléter Ronan notamment sur les
concernant effectivement les
statistiques locales et la qualité des
données notamment des DPE effectivement
on essaye un alerter dans nos études sur
le fait qu'il y a différents niveaux
d'incertitude dans les statistiques
autour des DPE l'incertitude liée à au
fait qu'on mesure un concept qui est le
fruit de finalement d'une mesure
administrative conventionnelle et donc
il peut évoluer dans le temps
qui peut être sujet finalement à
contestation notamment en fait c'est
c'est écrit dans le document de travail
sur les effets de seuil au niveau en
fait des changements de seuil de classe
de DPE ou pour les petits logements
et aussi en fait une incertitude liée
effectivement ça a été rappelé par
Bérengère Meski à au fait que c'est un
travail de modélisation alors en
parallèle en fait de ce qui a été publié
on a un travail en cours dans le cadre
de ce qu'on appelle une mission
connaissance avec la Dréal Normandie qui
vise à définir un outil
de dire qui s'appelle pour l'instant la
boussole de la rénovation énergétique
mais qui qui donnerait en fait des
statistiques à un niveau local plus fin
au niveau PCI autour autour des DPE
autour des aides à la rénovation
énergétique pour l'instant en fait la
question c'est quelle est la fiabilité
justement de ces chiffres au niveau
local parce qu'effectivement ça donne
une vision théorique de ce qu'est
finalement la situation du parc de
logement au des caractéristiques du parc
son ancienneté le nombre d'appartements
le nombre de maisons à la surface des
logements mais effectivement ça ne peut
pas tenir compte dans un niveau local
dans nos modélisations des politiques
spécifiques ont pu être mises en œuvre
et donc l'expertise locale des acteurs
dans ce cadre-là restent nécessaire pour
commenter évidemment ce type d'analyse
donc voilà concernant la qualité des
chiffres et de les analyses locales
effectivement sur sur la future enquête
Trello il y a des cadres qui existent
sur la connaissance des aides et
en fait à quel aide en fait ont eu
recours les ménages qu'on peut relier en
fait aux situations de revenus ou de
composition des ménages donc dans ce
cadre là effectivement il faudra qu'on
regarde le questionnaire pour
éventuellement voir si on peut il
inclure des une analyse de d'une recours
sur le non recours alors je pense que
c'est un sujet pour avoir travaillé la
dessus dans un autre cadre par le passé
c'est souvent très coûteux techniquement
voilà et on n'est jamais sûr d'avoir
parfaitement traité le sujet je pense
qu'en l'état actuel de notre système
d'information statistique je pense que
le sujet n'est très stable de manière à
peu près satisfaisante que sur le champ
du du logement social en fait voilà
parce que justement on a la variant etc
que j'évoquais on est en train de
l'implémenter dans le système le rpls le
répertoire du parc locatif social qu'on
gère justement dans notre sous-direction
donc là en terme de faisabilité pour moi
c'est la seule piste aujourd'hui
envisageable
la parole à nos collègues est-ce que
vous avez aujourd'hui éventuellement pu
déjà identifier le nombre de logements
qui serait déjà
aux normes de la stratégie nationale ma
carbone 2050 ou pas du tout est-ce que
ce sont des des points que vous avez
jamais exploré
en fait
on évalue le nombre de logements par
classe DPE dans nos documents de travail
dont notamment les logements AB et
celles alors après les normes BBC qui
sont l'horizon en fait de horizon 2005
ans la question c'est ce que quelle est
la définition qu'on adopte donc
effectivement on peut caractériser les A
et B donc quelle mesure on relie ça aux
normes d'efficacité énergétique des
bâtiments horizon 2050
en fait j'aurais du mal à me prononcer
strictement alors après j'ajouterai en
fait un autre point en fait de
difficulté quand même sur cette sur les
logements très performants sur le fait
sur le sur le point sur lequel on
communique moins mais qui est présent
évidemment dans le document de travail
c'est que il y a trois méthodes de
calcul du DPE donc une qui est la
méthode 3 cl conventionnelle et deux
autres qui sont pour les logements neufs
genre les normes aux
les normes auxquelles ces logements les
normes sur lesquels ces logements
s'appliquaient c'est-à-dire la RTA la
réglementaire réglementation thermique
2012 et la réglementation
environnementale 2020 mais donc en fait
il y a des DPE les DPE des logements
neufs conceptuellement ne sont pas les
mêmes que les DPE en fait en nombre 3 cl
et donc là en fait on essaye de remettre
tout le monde en norme 3 cl mais quelque
part pour les logements très efficaces
donc BBC on mélange un petit peu des
concepts différents puisque les concepts
des DPE ne sont pas les mêmes et donc ça
rend d'autant plus la mesure du nombre
de logements très efficace difficile
autour de cette des logements AB et une
partie d'essai
juste pour pour compléter faire pour
pour préciser sur sur le logement neuf
vous arrivez quand même à avoir les
données justement entre le nombre de
constructions qui sont RT 2012 BBC
passif etc quoi ça vous arrive à le
savoir après la vraie question c'est le
lien est l'uniformisation avec les
données de l'existant et de et des PE
c'est ça ouais c'est ça c'est à dire que
le notre travail de modélisation est sur
les logements 3 cl donc des logements
neufs qui potentiellement ont fait des
un despe3 cl parce qu'ils ont été
construits il y a 5 ans 6 ans et qui
renouvelle leur dpe en parallèle on
connaît la situation du parc des deux
dernières années des logements neufs et
donc on va utiliser ce qui l'information
sur les logements neuf pour faire
vieillir un petit peu nos statistiques
mais effectivement ça reste ça reste
assez incertain comme comme méthodologie
donc effectivement on a on a de la
connaissance sur le parc du logement
neuf mais on a du mal à la relier en
fait avec avec les concepts la
méthodologie 3L donc excusez-moi si
c'était un petit peu technique
où est-ce que c'est pas du tout quelque
chose que vous avez aujourd'hui dans le
viseur si j'ose dire
non enfin déjà c'est pas c'est pas le
rôle d'un service statistique donc on va
pas chercher spécifiquement les fraudes
ensuite sauf si on avait des données sur
les fraudes et lorsque là on pourrait
les analyser mais enfin a priori c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on
nous on a des statistiques qui donnent
qui a bénéficié des aides alors les
effets d'aubaine on pourrait si ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on pourrait
éventuellement regarder je sais pas très
bien comment aujourd'hui on pourrait le
pas déjà faudrait le définir
le phénomène
dans la rénovation
comme j'ai pas forcément une définition
très claire parce que pour être les
phénomènes sur une aide à la rénovation
des personnes qui puissent oui des
personnes qui l'auraient fait comme oui
alors c'est peut-être là c'est très
difficile à mesurer oui du coup c'est
pas plus que les phénomène c'est oui
l'effet incitatif des aides à la
rénovation et qui ont
on en est pas là je crois aujourd'hui
dans l'évolution
juste un élément enfin je sais pas si
c'est fraude ou pas c'est entre une aide
qui est mise en place et puis le
l'influence qui peut avoir sur le sur le
coup des matériaux mais si on prend
l'exemple l'exemple des chaudières par
exemple c'est quelque chose qui me
semble peut être assez facile à mesurer
en tout cas sur l'évolution des couples
que ce soit pour pas chaleur ou autre
ce que je vous disais au début c'est
qu'on a effectivement lancé un déjà un
groupe de travail pour pour voir comment
on pouvait suivre le coup des travaux de
rénovation donc on en est là au début à
essayer de de voir quelle source sont
les meilleurs à priori ce qu'on a des
données de coup dans les fichiers d'aide
à la rénovation c'est de passer deux
œufs mais dans les fichiers MPR
et donc c'est ça qu'on va utiliser pour
poursuivre effectivement les coûts et à
partir de ça on pourrait éventuellement
identifier un effet de de l'aide sur une
évolution
oui sur l'évolution d'un
matériau ou d'un dispositif spécifique
là encore pour l'instant on est déjà
essayé
d'obtenir des données un peu fiables sur
les coups qu'on puisse suivre dans le
temps et
on n'est pas encore à regarder l'effet
effectivement les professionnels le
disent
alors Franck Montauger
merci Madame merci madame la Présidente
merci pour ces présentations et ses
explications j'aurais deux questions qui
sont
éventuellement liés est-ce que vos
statistiques celles que vous avez
présentées
constituent la base de ce que les
cabinets les cabinets d'études utilisent
souvent en matière de coût d'émission de
carbone vous avez parmi les courbes que
vous ne l'avez présentées
donc indiqué des émissions de carbone
donc je voudrais savoir si
vos études servent de base assez calcule
qui sont utilisés
dans de nombreux endroits et notamment
pour les collectivités locales par
rapport à aux politiques qu'elles ont à
concevoir et à mettre en oeuvre ou en
tout cas auquel elle contribue ma
deuxième question toujours liée à vos
chiffres relatifs aux émissions de
carbone donc vous avez donné des
chiffres voilà brut des missions de
carbone est-ce que ces chiffres sont
intègres ou pas
la production de carbone des intrants
correspondant aux différentes opérations
que que vous avez qui sont envisageables
en matière d'économie d'énergie au
niveau des bâtiments
qu'il s'agissent de matériaux ou de ou
d'énergie voilà puisqu'une rénovation
peut donner lieu à un changement de
évidemment de mode de mode de chauffage
étant entendu que voilà ça peut aussi se
traduire ensuite par malgré tout des
émissions de carbone supplémentaires
voilà les deux questions que je voulais
c'est un peu technique mais pour être
sûr d'avoir bien compris merci
vous êtes déjà sur votre dernière
question là ce qu'on a c'est les
images donc on n'a pas l'empreinte
carbone des matériaux en revanche on a
les gains d'émissions liés à un
changement de mode de chauffage dire que
si on passe du fioul à l'électricité ça
diminue les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et ça ça se voit en revanche si on
a utilisé pour isoler un matériau qui
est particulièrement carboné on le voit
pas voilà c'est vraiment des émissions à
l'usage donc effectivement ça a assez
limite
sur la première question
alors
là on a fait ce qu'on a fait ici
je pense pas que ce soit réutilisé tel
quel dans des études enfin pas ma
connaissance là on a plutôt utilisé
on a calculé ces gains d'émissions à
partir des des gains théoriques
d'énergie et puis du type de chauffage
avec du coup une question une hypothèse
sur les facteurs d'émissions de chaque
mode de chauffage
ensuite est-ce que
dans la plupart des des études qui qui
peuvent être faites au niveau des
collectivités territoriales je pense que
il repartent un peu à la à la base des
des hémiciens des
données de la base carbone sur tel mode
de chauffage fait tel type d'émission
tel type de meuf enfin je sais pas quoi
tel
matériaux
[Musique]
mode de transport à tel type d'émission
enfin je pense que c'est pas forcément
réutiliser tel quel mais ma connaissance
il y a pas
il y a la question des
de la possibilité de comparer ou pas des
chiffres des chiffres des chiffres issus
de d'études différentes quoi voilà vous
par contre parce que je pense que la
base initiale c'est pas les données
initiales c'est les mêmes les facteurs
d'émission de chaque mode de chauffage
c'est effectivement des choses qui font
qui sont standards qui sont répertoriés
par la dame et qui font foi quoi donc
c'est des boss c'est des bases de
l'ADEME c'est ça
pour le calcul des gains conventionnels
notamment de consommation fuite GES on
s'appuie en fait sur une modélisation
conventionnelle type DPE et sur le
travail en fait pour certaines
hypothèses techniques effectivement d'un
travail d'un cabinet de consultant qui
permettent définir en fait certaines
hypothèses techniques associées aux
données de l'enquête pour pour pouvoir
en fait faire ces chiffrage ces
chiffrages là donc effectivement en fait
ce qui va c'est ça qui justifie que ce
soit comparable c'est que la plupart en
fait des acteurs pour utiliser la
méthodologie dpe en fait pour calculer
des liens conventionnels après
effectivement des fois il peut y avoir
des variantes selon les hypothèses qu'on
utilise et les données de trémie sont
quand même utilisés alors pas forcément
sur les gaz à effet de serre mais plutôt
sur l'aspect consommation ou hypothèse
sur les travaux dans d'autres modèles
macroéconomiques en données d'entrée
pour modéliser l'efficacité de certaines
mesures de politique publique de
rénovation énergétique
et dernier petit point qui peut être pas
le plus simple est-ce que vous avez une
une visio une appréciation
de l'efficacité de ces de ces labels de
cette classification dans le temps
c'est à dire ce qui est vrai aujourd'hui
tel que vous le mettez en évidence dans
vos études
peut-il se dégrader dans le tas
c'est-à-dire donner lieu à voilà une
moindre efficacité de rénovation le
temps passant
oui il y a une durée de vie des
équipements effectivement
qui selon les selon les études selon les
équipements je crois qu'on fait des
hypothèses dans les modèles
macroéconomiques d'une
des travaux de rénovation qui ont une
durée de vie de 20 ans ou 25 ans voilà
mais ça c'est
donc oui effectivement les émissions
qu'on calcule les gains d'émissions ou
le gain énergétique ont calcule là c'est
au moment où la rénovation est
fonctionnelle est efficace à 100% mais
ça peut ne pas durer
éternellement il peut y avoir besoin un
bout de 20 ans ou 25 ans
mais une chaudière c'est c'est 15-20 ans
l'isolation c'est dans les hypothèses
des modèles on prend plutôt 25 ans mais
ensuite je sais pas si ça a vraiment
s'il y a des fondements scientifiques
très robustes là dessus je sais que
c'est ce qu'on prend dans les modèles
mais
je pense qu'on n'a pas forcément encore
la visibilité sur sur tous les travaux
de rénovation qu'on fait aujourd'hui
pour connaître la durée de vie
c'est une chaudière on voit à peu près
mais sur les matériaux qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui dans l'isolation je sais pas
si on a une visibilité sur la durée de
vie de la durée d'efficacité de cette
isolation j'en suis pas certaine
Marie-Noëlle
mais tant mieux micro marinoles
la première question c'est celle entre
le calcul conventionnel et le constat
alors j'ai bien compris que vous alliez
mettre en place des études pour comparer
les les différentes mais ce qu'il
faudrait pas être un peu plus précis et
prendre statistiquement j'ai pas moi
1000 ménages type regardez je compare ça
avec l'observateur de l'air intérieur
pour comprendre la pollution de
l'intérieur on prend des ménages type on
leur demande d'écrire j'ai ouvert la
cocotte-minute à 17h c'est pas à 17h en
général mais bon et pour voir comment
l'air intérieur évolue au regard de la
de la vie réelle des gens
serait-il pas utile d'engager ça pour
parce que moi j'ai observé je suis ce
dossiers depuis longtemps des accidents
la propriété on leur dit votre DPE est
très bon machin vous allez faire des
économies d'énergie ils sont déjà
compris quand l'énergie augmentait les
économies n'allaient pas voir lieu mais
indépendamment même du prix de l'énergie
la quantité notamment d'électricité or
dans la même période ils ont comme moi à
plusieurs smartphones machin bidules qui
font qui consomment et qu'ils ont un
sentiment de frustration par rapport à
ce qu'on leur avait annoncé or la
crédibilité du DPO de l'un des
professionnels dont on a suivi les deux
péripéties
et quand même très important pour nos
concitoyens et même par rapport à leurs
calculs financiers sur la faisabilité
leurs investissements personnels donc
est-ce qu'il sait est-ce que cette étape
là est prévue à un moment ou un autre
dans vos travaux statistiques ou faut-il
les faire ailleurs ou sur d'autres
formes mais en tout cas ça me paraît un
point important puis alors là encore un
peu plus
comment dire provocatrice
ça fait longtemps que je lis beaucoup
beaucoup d'études et de statistiques
et je me demande si elle nous aide
vraiment
à définir les politiques publiques
je dis pas que faut pas connaître toute
connaissance est bonne mais cette espèce
d'obsession de la pensée par les comptes
les statistiques et les chiffres on va
trouver la solution problème je l'ai
jamais vu bon donc je m'interroge pour
vous demander est-ce que à travers vos
études il y a des faits saillants qui
vous auraient paru finalement pas si
évident que ça
si je puis dire dans les milieux un peu
concernés qui à travers les statistiques
révèlent des fragilités des nécessités
des sujets qui au fond apparaissent
réellement de nouveaux parce que
honnêtement c'est celle qui connaissent
ces sujets depuis un moment même sans
être et des hyper spécialiste
pensait que c'est les riches qui font
plus de travaux que le pavillon pollue
plus que le collectif je caricature mais
que les on sait tous que les
fenêtres c'est moins important que les
toitures et pourtant les gens font les
fenêtres vraiment donc il y a voilà ma
question un peu c'est ce que vous avez
vous découvert à travers votre travail
parce que ça nous ramène à un débat
philosophique sur est-ce que ce qui
compte ce compte c'est un sujet qui est
aujourd'hui on a tout besoin de compter
et puis après on est tétanisé pour
décider donc voilà c'est c'est pas pour
remettre en cause la structure qui par
ailleurs n'est pas inutile
alors j'ai répondu déjà sur la première
question qui me paraissait plus facile
c'est la question de enfin je pense que
les deux exercices effectivement enfin
nous ce qu'on va faire c'est un exercice
assez macro on va regarder la
consommation d'un million de ménages les
évolution des consommations réelles
qu'on va à parier aux aides et aux
données fiscales donc on va quand même
avoir des informations sur la
composition du logement
le type du logement etc donc ça ça nous
permettra de voir effectivement un
niveau un peu macroéconomique en
comparant des ménages qui ont résolvé
des ménages qui ont pas rénovés l'impact
de la rénovation soit la consommation
réelle je pense que ça c'est quand même
déjà un premier chose importante ensuite
effectivement de connaître précisément
quels usage à quel moment quand
l'efficacité de la rénovation sur la
consommation n'est pas aussi importante
qu'on attendait qu'est-ce qui a con
enfin qu'est-ce qui s'est passé c'est
aussi quelque chose de qui qui sont
utiles aujourd'hui nous on n'a pas prévu
de le faire je sais qu'il y avait
quand même des projets autour d'un panel
avec RTE et puis j'ai pu exactement qui
participaient au projet mais je pense
qu'il y avait RTE la dame est
potentiellement les distributeurs
d'électricité et de gaz je garantis pas
à 100% mais voilà il y avait il y a une
idée de panel comme ça donc sur un plus
petit échantillon pour pouvoir suivre
effectivement leur consommation le
branchement de la voiture électrique et
pouvoir analyser ça mais pour l'instant
enfin nous c'est un projet qu'on suit un
peu qu'on suit mais auquel on participe
pas plus que ça et je pense que ça n'est
enfin ça n'est pas encore rendu de
résultat aujourd'hui mais c'est
effectivement je pense deux types de
travaux complémentaires et qui ont tous
les deux leur intérêt
c'est une question
oui je suis d'accord qu'il y a quand
même beaucoup de choses qu'on connaît
ensuite sur les montants par exemple le
chiffrage des montants d'économie
d'énergie ce qu'on va avoir peut-être
avec les économie réelle sur le montant
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
pour avoir un peu une connaissance sur
l'ampleur de ce que la rénovation
énergétique peut apporter aux politiques
aux objectifs de la SNBC notamment je
pense que ça moi c'est des choses que je
ne maîtrise pas enfin que je maîtrisais
pas avant donc si on n'a pas mesuré à
partir des enquêtes à partir de trémy à
partir des aides on peut pas le faire
voilà donc je pense que là il y a quand
même
les statistiques sont quand même
intéressantes pour pour la définition
des politiques publiques il y a plein
d'autres sujets
assez pauvre en complément mais je
trouve madame la sénatrice que votre
question est un peu déstabilisante parce
que précisément madame wargon nous a
demandé de précisément de produire de la
statistique sur la rénovation
énergétique parce que justement il
n'existait rien donc
certes on a probablement pas découvert
de choses
fondamentales mais en même temps il n'y
avait pas de mesure donc nous le mandat
qui nous a été demandé c'était de créer
des indicateurs de mesure et comme je
vous le disais comme Bérengère là aussi
exposé
il me semble qu'on a plutôt bien rempli
le mandat voilà dans un temps qui est
quand même assez court voilà
maintenant et ce qui compte ce compte
alors effectivement je suis d'accord
avec vous c'est un débat relativement
philosophique mais en même temps votre
votre intervention me fait penser au
recensement de la population où on dit
tout le monde compte voilà donc il me
semble que ça fait d'une certaine
manière éco je pense que on est tous
d'accord autour de la table pour dire
que le ressenton de la population
notamment pour les finances des
collectivités locales et vraiment
fondamentale
qui voulait prendre la parole
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers
de celle que viennent de poser mon notre
collègue
concernant les les modes et les éléments
de certification donc des
différents produits et au-delà de leur
de leur processus de fabrication
je m'explique et à partir d'un exemple
concret
dans notre région donc d'Occitanie et
plus particulièrement
dans le secteur de l'Aveyron et du Sud
Aveyron et surtout en ce qui me concerne
de l'Est du Tarn nous avons une une
importante donc d'important cheptel au
vin
relative à la filière roquefort
et il y a un sous-produit qui est la
laine qui est souvent pas très bien
utilisé ou valorisé pour pour tout un
tas de raisons je vais pas rentrer dans
celle-ci et l'isolation
étonne un élément qui peut être un
élément intéressant parce que c'est
somme toute la valorisation d'un
sous-produit
qui a un impact environnemental égal à
zéro par rapport à d'autres isolants et
qui sont des isolants fait à partir de
pétrole ou autre mais pour lesquelles
les éléments de labellisation sont
beaucoup plus complexes et puis vous
allez pas demander à un agriculteur qui
qui va livrer sa laine de faire toutes
les démarches de certification parce que
c'est tout totalement
irréaliste et donc dans ce cadre là je
voulais savoir s'il n'y avait pas de
selon vous des éléments et des
possibilités pour faire de telle sorte
que l'on puisse utiliser donc des
matériaux locaux qui sont pour prendre
une terminologie à l'amende biosourcée
et qui
sont toutes peuvent répondre à un besoin
mais sans rentrer dans le cadre des
éléments purement statistiques
au regard du fait que ils n'obtiennent
pas ou que c'est difficile d'avoir un
label proprement structuré par rapport
par rapport à cela pour être encore plus
concret je vois dans mon village on est
en train de réaliser un projet avec des
maisons ossature bois et sur lesquels on
a décidé d'utiliser donc la laine comme
isolant mais on s'aperçoit assez
rapidement que on rentre pas dans des
cadres y compris pour bénéficier du fond
vert
on nous dit mais oui mais c'est pas tout
à fait prévu dans le truc parce qu'il
manque la normalisation
exacte
par rapport par rapport à ça je voulais
avoir votre votre sentiment sur sur cet
aspect des choses
alors nous c'est vrai que dans les
statistiques souvent on est dépendant
des fichiers administratifs qui comptent
ce qui est effectivement labellisé enfin
dans les aides dans les fichiers d'aide
on compte ce qui a le droit à une aide
et donc effectivement ça parfois ça
limite le champ de ce qu'on peut voir
ensuite c'est pour ça qu'on fait aussi
des études plus générales enfin des
enquêtes en population générale comme
l'enquête des travaux de rénovation dans
les maisons individuelles qui permettent
de
capter ce qui est pas forcément ce qui
rendent pas forcément dans des cases de
l'administration donc il donne pas
forcément droit à une aide ou chez des
bêtises
qui n'est pas forcément labellisée donc
ça permet d'en avoir une vision
ensuite sur la labellisation du méthodes
enfin c'est vrai que ça relève pas du
service statistique donc nous on
comprend les difficultés mais c'est vrai
que en tant que statisticien on a aussi
cette difficulté qu'on mesure quand même
plus facilement ce qui est déjà
labellisé donc on essaie de ne pas se
restreindre à ça et d'avoir une vision
plus large
Sabine Draxler
merci beaucoup alors vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure la motivation des ménages
pour réaliser les travaux d'isolation
alors on sait que cette motivation va
forcément évoluer puisque le DPE va
devenir obligatoire et opposable pour
pouvoir continuer à louer son son bien
alors j'aimerais savoir si vous
envisagez ou si vous aviez les moyens
pour évaluer en fait le nombre de
propriétaires bailleurs qui va renoncer
à effectuer des travaux d'isolation
notamment sur du bâti patrimonial du
bâti d'avant 1948 qui nécessite
justement des gestes et des et des
matériaux particuliers notamment des
matériaux biosourcés j'aimerais savoir
aussi si vous allez évaluer le nombre de
biens qui sera ensuite délaissés puis
des Molly faute d'avoir été justement
dans ce cadre là parce que c'est
difficile d'avoir plus difficile on va
dire a priori
est-ce que est-ce que vous vous
envisagez d'évaluer en fait ce cette le
nombre de maisons qui vont être démolis
pour une remise sur le marché du terrain
puisqu'on sait très bien que dans le
cadre d'usane le terrain va devenir rare
et cher et qu'on risque de voir une
spéculation foncière très forte nous
arrivait et qu'on pense que le bâti
patrimonial peut être en danger dans ce
cadre là et ma dernière question
est-ce que pour vous l'objectivité des
DPE et la qualification des
diagnostiqueurs est un sujet
alors sur la première question on a
enfin nous là aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
travaux
vraiment déjà prévu sur
sur l'impact de l'interdiction à la
location de certains DPE des
interdictions à venir sur le marché du
logement mais c'est quand même une
réflexion qui que
qu'on a alors peut-être pas pas dans les
travaux prévus aujourd'hui aux DAEs mais
on sait que on a échangé avec la DHP qui
se pose des questions là-dessus avec
le Centre Conseil d'analyse économique
pardon qui qui veut aussi évaluer
l'impact sur le marché du logement donc
il y a des études qui qui vont se mettre
en place mais à ce stade il me semble
qu'il y a pas grand chose
à ce stade rien de très très précis sauf
peut-être effectivement le
cadre il y a la mission de coordination
sur la rénovation énergétique coordonne
justement des travaux sur la feuille de
route sur la mise en place de la
rénovation énergétique dans le parc
locatif privé et vis-à-vis des
propriétaires bailleurs
il y a une demande aussi politique très
forte du ministre du Logement vis-à-vis
de cette thématique et dans ce cadre là
effectivement le NRE ne répond pas en
fait à cette question en fait de mesure
du nombre de logements qui qui sont
directement
qui vont arrêter d'être mis en location
qui vont sortir du parc etc donc on va
publier en fait un document de travail
complémentaire sur les DPE en fait
spécifiques ou au parc locatif privé
mais en parallèle effectivement il y a
eu des échanges avec des acteurs privés
en l'occurrence meilleurs agents qui ont
publié des études en fait voilà
basé sur d'autres données alors après
avec effectivement une qualité qui reste
aussi toujours à questionner des travaux
sérieux mais mais voilà qui qui complète
sur des certains aspects conjoncturels
ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut faire voilà
c'est pas c'est pas les travaux de l'on
re mais voilà il y a des échanges aussi
avec d'autres acteurs pour essayer de
mesurer ce phénomène
oui sur l'objectivité des DPE je l'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure
nous en fait on prend les concepts ça a
été dit aussi par Bérengère Meski on se
base sur des concepts administratifs qui
préexistent en fait pour faire nos
statistiques
on essaye toujours d'être finalement
prudent en fait dans nos quand on
valorise nos analyses et qu'on diffuse
les statistiques après on sait
évidemment on suit l'actualité on sait
qu'il y a eu beaucoup de débats en fait
mais après je dirais que voilà on a mis
en avant par exemple dans le document de
travail des effets de seuil
on n'y est pas en fait voilà il y a eu
on n'y pas aussi que qu'on a mis en
place là ce document de travail la
chaîne par exemple informatique de
remonter de l'information despeux n'est
pas encore tout à fait stabilisé donc
depuis ça c'est largement améliorée en
termes de de redemonter de l'information
de prise en compte par les
diagnostiquers de certains certaines
hypothèses après effectivement nous on
ne juge pas de on ne peut pas juger
directement de la qualité
stricte au sang sud de la méthode DPE et
effectivement il peut rester des biais
des biais en fait sur certains points
voilà sur les petits logements ça déjà
été dit il y a certainement en fait des
améliorations qui pourraient être
effectuées sur la mesure du DPE des
petits logements qui sont très fortement
dépasseoirs du fait de critères de
consommation par mètre carré dans ses
logements
je suis sur le le
votre question portant sur les biens
démolis en termes d'observation donc il
y a une source qui s'appelle citadelle
donc vous avez peut-être entendu parler
qui est donc alors on dit souvent le
répertoire des permis de construire mais
en fait on engrange aussi les permis de
démolir alors pas tous parce que
historiquement c'est vrai que il y avait
un effet de un effet d'intérêt pour
cette source qui était de plutôt suivre
les projets de construction neuve de
projet de se traduisant par des
logements voilà ou des locaux voilà donc
on observe depuis quelques années
effectivement beaucoup d'intérêt pour
les projets de démolition pour disposer
de statistiques pérennes sous forme de
séries chronologique sur la démolition
aujourd'hui on n'est pas complètement
armé pour le faire mais par contre on
l'a on a bien identifié le besoin
aujourd'hui c'est clair on peut pas
répondre à cette question il faut quand
même dire que
beaucoup de alors on a quand même un
certain nombre de projets de démolition
qui sont engrangés dans la base mais
faut savoir et on l'oublie souvent que
beaucoup de constructions neufs se font
sur des projets de structure anciennes
qui sont pas nécessairement démolis
voilà donc il y a souvent beaucoup de
beaucoup de construction sur existant de
reconstruction sur existant avec un nom
de supérieur ou inférieur de logement
même quelquefois on repart évidemment
sur une structure qui originellement
n'était pas vouée à faire du résidentiel
quoi voilà donc on a bien ça en tête
mais aujourd'hui effectivement le
système d'information statistique est
plutôt en fragilité sur ce sujet et puis
il y a la question des locaux parce que
effectivement
le zéro artificialisation nette aussi ne
concerne pas que le résidentiel il peut
y avoir aussi du recyclage de friche
industrielles etc voilà et là là-dessus
aussi on est encore un peu en fragilité
d'observation pour être clair
en parlant de démolition vous faites un
écart entre l'habité les 5 millions de
passoires thermiques et les 7 2 avec les
résidences secondaires voilà j'allais
vous demander si vous avez fait une
étude spécifique sur dans tous les
logements vacants quelle est la part de
patients thermiques parce que une des
raisons des logements vacants pourrait
être quand même l'extrême mauvaise
qualité et il y a pas aujourd'hui
beaucoup alors il y avait jadis le
bailleur réhabilitation qui était un des
outils qui est très peu utilisé mais
peut-être qu'il y aurait là quand même
un travail de de voir comment on peut
inciter parce que aujourd'hui on taxe
bon je suis très favorable à la taxe
mais s'il y a plein de travaux à faire
on va continuer à taxer mais ça restera
vacances donc le peut-être ça mériterait
un focus sur tendanceiellement ils
doivent être beaucoup plus passoire
thermique les autres
spontanément on doit penser ça mais ça
mériterait peut-être d'être surtout en
zone urbaine parce que
ils sont pas taxés au moins ceux qui
sont taxés
la difficulté va être du logement
vacances c'est que
Jérôme va me corriger mais c'est la
vacances au sens fiscales en fait donc
il y a une partie de vacances qui est
frictionnelle aussi donc au moment de la
mesure donc ça regroupe en fait un
ensemble de situations très diverses
donc effectivement
en tout cas en tout cas voilà donc ça ça
regroupe une un ensemble de situations
très diverses et qu'il est assez
difficile d'étudier aussi pour les
résidences secondaires en fait la
connaissance en fait de ces parcs là est
plus et plus faible et pour
effectivement la volonté de d'avoir mis
en avant ces chiffres là dans le
document DPE justement concernant
l'utilité des statistiques c'est qu'il y
avait beaucoup en fait de débats sur le
nombre de passoires et là ça voulait
alerter sur le fait que dans les DPE
bien sûr c'est majoritairement des
résidences principales il y a quand même
cette question de réallocation du départ
qui se pose et ça visait aussi à poser
cette question là mais effectivement on
répond pas on répond pas à tout
Michel Dagbert
merci Madame présidente merci pour
l'exposé merci pour les précisions que
vous nous apportez et l'ensemble des
données qui aujourd'hui commencent à
être collecté et qu'ils le seront à
l'avenir mais vous avez évoqué une
expérimentation conduite par la DREAL
donc je suis toujours très attentif à
l'état déconcentré et je suis aussi
attentif à la manière dont les élus se
saisissent dans les territoires de ces
problématiques là
quelle est la relation qui est la vôtre
avec les remontées des des différentes
structures intercommunales je pense aux
communautés urbaines aux communautés
d'agglomération qui commence aujourd'hui
à se structurer d'un point de vue
administratif et technique et peut-être
aussi les communautés de communes qui
sont peut-être d'une ampleur et qui sont
peut-être moins outillés est-ce que vous
avez déjà imaginé qu'elle pouvait être
demain la relation entre
votre structure et les différents
partenariats qu'il faudrait nouer pour
avoir une remontée plus fine et
notamment sur les derniers sujets qui
viennent d'être évoqués notamment sur
les démolitions les reconstructions à
l'heure où nous allons entrer dans le 0
artificialisation nette
à ce stade on n'a pas forcément de
remonter qui vient de des communautés de
communes peut-être sur le logement mais
sauf dans des bases déjà enfin déjà
cadré quoi
peut-être
ouais pourquoi en fait donc il y a au
sein du CGDD donc de commissaire général
de développement durable donc il y a une
mission connaissance qui vise à
finalement coordonner des pôles au sein
des drags de statistiques locales mais à
viser nationale donc il y a il y en a à
l'adréal Normandie qui porte sur la
rénovation énergétique mais il y en a
d'autres sur la certification
artificialisation des sols ou d'autres
ou l'eau ou d'autres sujets et donc
l'objectif effectivement nous dans ce
cadre là c'est un projet qui se monte et
donc ce qui est prévu en termes de
gouvernance et que ce soit porté
effectivement par l'adréal que dans un
premier temps l'outil soit mise à la
disposition interne de l'administration
des DT des Dréal des préfectures ce qui
nous permettrait effectivement d'avoir
une remontée déjà de nous de la qualité
en fait statistique par rapport à tout
ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure sur sur la
pertinence des statistiques locales
après ponctuellement on a pu avoir des
questions évidemment de communauté de
communes en fait sur nos statistiques
mais ça restait très ponctuel
effectivement l'idée c'est plutôt que
nous on fournisse en fait des des
statistiques un outil des éléments
statistiques à l'adréal Normandie qui
elle pilote en fait finalement la
relation avec les acteurs mais c'est
c'est pas prévu que ce soit nous-mêmes
qui qui
interagissent avec l'ensemble des
comités avec des comités de communes ou
autre et dans l'ensemble c'est plutôt
des statistiques nationales qu'on essaie
de décliner puisque des remontées
locales qu'on pourrait agréger
d'expérience pour l'avoir fait sur
d'autres sujets l'agrégation de
statistiques locales qui sont pas au
même formats qui sont pas collectés de
la même façon c'est pas complètement
évident
bien sûr par ailleurs en fait nous on
travaille avec un réseau de
statisticiens régionaux andréal voilà
donc et donc effectivement on est dans
un système quand même assez Jacobins
faut quand même bien le dire et donc on
a un partage des rôles donc nous on les
dessous direction travaillent dans une
approche plutôt Nationale Territoriale
en clair donc des indicateurs qui sont
plutôt normés à l'échelle nationale et
qu'on décline effectivement
progressivement parce que il faut aussi
bien sûr s'assurer de la qualité des
indicateurs aux différents échelons ce
qui a été dit tout à l'heure et puis à
partir de d'un certain moment
effectivement on sera en capacité de
mettre assez de manière assez fluide à
la disposition des collègues dans les
Dréal les indicateurs qu'on aura établis
au niveau national et puis je terminerai
par peut-être un petit rappel c'est que
par ailleurs on travaille en assez
étroite collaboration avec le réseau des
cercles
les cellules éc régional pour la
construction qui ont également une
structure nationale qui vise à
harmoniser les méthodologies à
coordonner etc cette structure nationale
est d'ailleurs en partie subventionnée
par le CGDD voilà avec les fédérations
professionnelles au niveau national et
donc aussi le GIE réseau dessert que
travail de manière assez parallèle avec
nous mais coordonnées à un outil qui
s'appelle mon suivi rénov et qui a pour
fonction pour objet justement de mettre
un outil assez commode à la disposition
des acteurs locaux
mais donc je serai très bref mais mais
j'assiste quand même sur le fait que je
lis les deux parce que on est
aujourd'hui sur ce travail là avec le
zéro artificialisation nette et ça
risque d'avoir des effets induits y
compris parfois des effets pervers sur
certains comportements et je pense que
aujourd'hui d'un point de vue
méthodologique je comprends bien la
sécurisation des données et c'est
important il pourrait y avoir là aussi
un accompagnement des des EPCI en termes
méthodologie et je pense que ça pourrait
avoir un intérêt dans les les années qui
viennent pour voir comment les choses
vont évoluer de ce point de vue là et
notamment j'entends bien vous avez des
partenariats mais je pense notamment la
Fédération des agences d'urbanisme par
exemple pourrait nous nous donner des
indications très utiles à l'avenir
dans le suivi de la mise en oeuvre du
zinc
quelques quelques pistes de proposition
et de réflexion qui sont portées à votre
votre votre volonté voilà en tout cas
merci beaucoup de ces échanges la
présentation de cette étude qui est
quand même très intéressante et puis on
suivra les études à venir ou en tout cas
peut-être donc dans le courant de
l'année 2023 que vont suivre souvent
être oui les consommations réelles c'est
plutôt fin 2023
merci beaucoup messieurs dames bonne fin
de journée à vous